so while Daniel may have gone into the
filming of the final movie feeling great
about a lack of quidditch scenes he was
about to get a lot more uncomfortable as
were Emma and rert Grint there's a scene
towards the end of the movie where the
three of them are carried by a dragon
out of gring guts but instead of a
gentle landing on say land the kids are
dropped into a lake from quite a high
distance but it wasn't even the drop or
getting soaked that made the day
uncomfortable it was the fact that the
lake itself was freezing and because of
the schedule of filming the next scene
the actors weren't allowed to wear
anything under their costumes to protect
them I mean you'd think not giving
actors hypothermia would Trump
scheduling but hey what do I know said
Emma quote the lake wasn't heated and
because we had to get changed as part of
the next scene we couldn't wear anything
underneath I was lucky I had my bottom
half with some thermals on but I was
like this must be a joke it was so cold
she also mentioned that rert was so cold
that he at one point thought his heart
had stopped beating what